oh pardon me pardon me you squished my
91.3 4% impossible that's awfully
specific haha Wow okay all right we're
gonna okay all right we're gonna die oh
whoa I got this in the bag
I think old men and stop humping each
other in a big man Love Train fans gonna
hide it in flight Wow Wow hopefully this
does not kill me immediately so far so
good
go so fast food fast walking past in the
moment oh oh so good oh so bad go god
he's gonna kill me they're gonna kill me
no they're gonna kill me Oh God
I'm alive I can't believe it I'm alive I
just fly over a mother good oh my balls
okay just gonna ain't gonna stop me I
know exactly what I'm doing now and I
know how to beat you oh wow you could
ease we're gonna try a bottle run but
not gonna be that we're gonna be good at
it so get back on the back on the back
and back on the back all right kiddies
we're gonna cheat this time because
we're not losing a minute anyway flying
okay we're gonna cheat in small bursts
kitties we're gonna cheat
I was supposed to balance on that thing
instead of a horrible Oh God son don't
die
whatever you do see son you never listen
to me what is this what crazy game is
this yeah I'm gonna eat this and if I
eat the landmine it won't cause me
bodily harm all right come on no you're
going the wrong way bro no go the other
okay
well this seems fun fly oh God not doing
well legs are gone and I'm still alive
kind of I don't feel okay this might be
a bit more challenging than I first
moving to the finish
it's brutal oh okay how did I win this
last time have you no not like that or
maybe like that because I lost my son
Wow handstand ow ass blam
I'm still on bounce off the wall bounce
off the wall and bend your knees fun but
not easy what is that supposed to mean
oh that's what that means but further oh
my but still my butt so now you're gonna
take one of these take it in the morning
with one of these no no oh my god it
gave it right back to me oh that's
awesome
suck on that [ __ ] that was easy oh no
where you going lady I'll save you oh oh
lady you're so good okay I'm sorry
wow I'm a unicorn now can my pelvic
thrusts of undulation break this glass
apparently oh it can okay just got a
move really can't kill my boss yeah
our poon run ultimate I'm a baby
no I'm beyond a baby where am I going oh
I'm going Wow look at me go I'm some art
deco [ __ ] where am I
did I overshoot it Wow oh you kiddies
it's time for the big guns on this
heartburn run okay
dude you're flying juice grape the
bottom with mobile know I'm very dead
not like that not like that I was very
good this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye